yeah in terms of what I've been watching
well I I actually want to besides
everything that's why besides everything
because it's like end of the year and
this is like the time I have to watch
everything I guess I had like some I was
thinking what would I recommend to you
boys since I assumed you guys were not
were not watching anime
well not as much as you and what is it
that you could possibly miss you know
right I mean the golf one sounds right
up my alley okay no I I go I got one for
you Joey I got one for you I'm listening
all right you've probably heard of this
before
um but it's not it's not mainstream yeah
it's not it's not mainstream yet that's
good that's a good start
um Bocce The Rock I'm like what do you
mean that's [__] everywhere is it
everywhere just annoying me about it to
be fair I have started watching you you
wouldn't like that corner I know I I saw
it it was like it's so good though I'm
like guys I just you don't want me to
watch it because I'm gonna [__] on it
don't ask me don't ask me save it save
washing around from Connor you don't
want me to watch this because I'm not
gonna react the way you want me to like
I'm gonna probably hate it because it's
yeah it's fun and you like it like I
just know I'm not gonna like that yeah
yeah I mean you can watch it for bands
if you want but like I'm telling you
you're not gonna like it yeah but I
almost want you to watch it just to hear
what just to hear your opinions
uh yeah but yes to be fair I have
started watching oh yeah yeah I'm a
couple of episodes in yeah yeah I mean
it's like you know what you're not the
only one who was like you would love
this show Joey like literally everyone
has been like yeah you would like this
you would because you like chaon right
yeah and I love this is like better
chaon yes I [__] said it okay I'm
gonna start a war right now
it could have been as bad as bang dream
it's all right yeah it's it's literally
like you know I can see why people like
Keon I personally didn't like hey on
um but it's everything that I wanted K
on to be yeah you know because it has
this mix of you know cute girls doing
cute things stuff but then they're
actually they actually like trying to
get [__] done and I'm like okay now I
can get behind I think I think the word
you're looking for is they actually have
a personality
because let's be real as much as I love
Kion not really like a an Eclectic cast
of characters you know where it's like
oh wow she's this girl and she's this
goal it's like it's very surface level
with K1 but I mean obviously Kion never
took itself seriously in that respect so
it's fine yeah but like yeah no I I
totally agree like I've only a couple of
episodes in obviously some preserving
like full judgment on it but yeah
already I can see like yeah I can see
why a lot of people say like this is
like the better chaon yeah or I guess
not the I guess the deeper K on is it's
it's it's it's different yeah I was just
like I just left a [__] on Care on fans
but it's not really the same show aside
from the fact that it's cute girls
making a band but I mean there's been
this recent Trend in anime that I don't
like I haven't really been able to get
behind and it's because I call it like
she just like me for real shows where
it's um it's just this show where this
cute girl is just like socially awkward
oh here we go again you're talking about
water motor I'm talking about water mode
[__] Comey song
um
not nagatora actually I'm sure there
were some girls or some guys oh yeah
just like me for real yeah but just
these socially awkward anime characters
and it's just like oh look at me look at
me guys I'm so cute because I can't talk
to people look at me I hate it so much
but like one thing that surprised me
about Bocce the rock is that it totally
goes down that route but they convey
moments using animation that
like that you relate with on like a
[__] it hits you in your soul how
much it hurts sometimes like seeing her
go through these different situations is
the same kind of situation that are
portrayed in these other shows but they
go so off the walls with like that
animation that it just it it turns it
into almost like a meme which is why I
think Bocce The Rock has been so
widespread on like Twitter so many
reaction here because the entire show is
just a living meme because there's so
many like there's so many moments where
it's so relatable that it just becomes
it just becomes a meme in and of itself
no and and I think that's you know
another huge reason why like you know
when when Co when commission was airing
right like yeah why you saw so many
[__] reaction images for of like
Comey son right because it's like yeah
as you said it's it's like it's just
like me for real right and it's like
they purposely they purposely make the
faces of the characters reacting in
certain ways to be so memorable in like
the reader or the watch is mine yeah
it's just like it's just like yep
immediately you have to like you know
like another one one of those shows that
I just couldn't [__] stand when it
was airing was like umarishan right like
oh my God I know I hate to I hate to
bring this up again yeah and I hate
beating a dead horse but like Mario
channel was like another show where it
was like so many people watching Mario
channel was just like oh she played
video game and she doesn't work she's
just like me for real dog this is why I
like Golden Boy because he likes MILFs
and he Cycles everything and that's why
I was like Dead Boys
25 years old close enough and he likes
MILFs and he wants to cycle of it and he
just Cycles around people I'm just like
damn he just like me for real yeah I I
just I don't know what it is that I've
realized now I was like for the longest
time I wondered like why haven't I
watched nichu Joe and I was like I think
I just don't want to watch schoolgirls
yeah I just don't care to watch girls in
school yeah I'm just kind of like I
don't know if I this if that's me like
I'm a Google Chat mindset don't wanna
I'm like I just I just don't I don't
know why I think think Nishi Joe is an
exception because yes you know some of
the characters are school girls and a
lot of the jokes are based in the school
yeah but the jokes are so incredibly
absurd to the point where it doesn't
matter I know that's why I want to watch
it yeah but I think other shows like can
we can't communicate and all those type
of shows I'm just like I don't think I
care no no no I actually agree that's
why Bocce like that was my biggest
surprise of the year because I came into
it being like I'm gonna hate this but
I'm watching this because this is my job
and I watched it because I I watched it
because you know I was making my end of
year video and I'm like [__] this is
actually really good I relate to this on
a level that I did not like that I did
not think and I remember I was like is
it is it is it a me thing I mean am I am
I like is it just is is it just
something weird or is it is this show
actually good so I convinced Sydney to
watch it with me as well and there were
literally some scenes where uh we were
we would be watching it together and
Sydney like literally just like it just
goes oh
you know the the very Sydney way to do a
very normal reaction
almost in the reaction and uh I go
Sydney what what's going on she's like
[__] I hate it I hate it I get out of my
mind get out of my mind because we've
there'd be several scenes where she you
know but she does something cringe and
this would that like that would just
unlock a core memory that Sydney had
just buried away doing cringe things
that she forgotten about and like
watching that show unlocks like 10
different core memories per episode uh
which is I think the real magic of bocce
where it just it takes these moments and
if you've ever been a cringed teenager
in your life which a lot of us have uh
including me
um there will be something in there that
you will just make you remember
something shitty why do you want to
relive that huh why would you want to
relive being cringe ah oh no it's just
uh I don't know why you want every I
don't know why you'd want to relive that
but it's just you know it's just
something that you relate to I guess I
think I think what I respect about botch
of the rock so far is like you know what
like yes you know the cringe elements
are obviously like you know very you
know hashtag relatable but I think how
they portray those certain scenes is one
like probably some of the most realistic
like representations of like real life
situations that have happened to people
and I feel like they do it in like a
tasteful way where it's like also funny
where because like that's one of the
huge reasons why I couldn't [__]
stand Watton right because it's like
they took the cringe aspect to such a
degree where it was just like a just
unrealistic yeah and B it was just like
painful to watch like there was no like
there was nothing that I could like
watch in a particular water mode I see
where I'm like like there was none of
that right but whereas with Bocce they
do it in like a comedic way but also in
a very realistic yeah I love it like
whenever whenever like something cringe
happens she just like goes she goes low
res and she goes deviantART like yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'm like [__] man I feel
that like I feel that that is so much
more of like a realistic like
representation of how you would feel in
a situation right like that right
whereas in watamote like what does she
do she just [__] shits her pants and
goes home right like it's it's not it's
not fun to watch I I like that show she
just [__] so fast yeah like it's not
funny yeah I like that show because it
was a real good indication of which
people to ignore online yeah like
everyone who had a watermote uh profile
picture you straight up ignore them yeah
exactly sure
um yeah this is this is one scene I know
you guys gonna tell us who that has
happened like many many times just to
like paying an example of like something
okay so they're out you know they're out
as a group of mates um and they're
trying to take a picture for their bands
um and every time they try to take a
picture Bocce just has the worst [__]
stupidest face in every picture that
they take and I'm like she's just like
me for real
and I'm like oh that's a word that's
never happened to me what why are you
why are you doing this to me Bocce why
are you [__] doing this to me and
then the girl's like oh we should post
this online and boji just has like a
mental breakdown and I'm like I've never
had a mental breakdown but like
internally I'm like Joey are you [__]
posting this online God I have an entire
like catalog of photos of me and God
where God just has like how did you pull
that face off in a split second just
like add like out of context gone faces
are just a thing not just on trash taste
subreddit but just in our life and it's
always been that she's been that's just
been my [__] life I know you relate
to it